à 15h 30 donc à peu près la petite Lola
donc rentre du collège et là qu'est-ce
qui se passe
à 15 ans quand elle sort du collège
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle rencontre
cette rencontre cette cette
Dabia devant devant
chez sa sœur qui est locataire en titre
d'un appartement dans l'immeuble de donc
qui est dans la résidence dans
l'immeuble au-dessus de du domicile des
parents de l'Olympe c'est dans
l'immeuble pour ses parents et donc là
on a lu on a eu plein de choses
qu'est-ce qui va se passer elle arrive
alors il y a des choses qu'on peut lire
des choses qu'on peut pas dire parce
qu'on est
je vous m'excuserez ma pudeur mais vous
avez bien raison
quand elle l'enferme dans l'appartement
de sa sœur elle l'oblige à prendre une
douche donc elle lui demande de se
déshabiller et elle lui demande de faire
sa toilette
ensuite elle va avoir des des
attouchements d'ordre sexuel à caractère
sexuel
réciproque elle lui impose de faire un
certain nombre de choses et elle lui
fait un certain nombre de choses je
crois que ce soit utile
tout ça dure en tout deux heures quand
même et
[Musique]
elle l'attache elle la Bayonne et c'est
d'ailleurs ce bâillon qui sera à
l'origine de sa mort puisque les causes
de la mort selon le médecin légiste
c'est l'étouffement elle s'est étouffée
probablement dans
il y a pas eu que ça mais c'est la
principale cause de la mort c'est
l'étouffement et post mortem elle va
donner un certain nombre de coups de
couteau de coûte ciseaux également elle
va massacrer ce pauvre petit ce pauvre
petit corps
elle dira un certain nombre de choses je
pense pas que ça soit très utile de
d'aller mais quel genre de choses
elle a déclaré qu'elle avait bu le sang
de sa victime
et a priori ça semble pas possible
d'accord
pourquoi on a évoqué la piste du trafic
d'organ dans cette affaire à un moment
c'est elle qui en parle à un témoin
enfin c'est des Roumains je crois qui
était dans une camionnette parce qu'elle
était perdue là sur ce trottoir de la
rue de la rue Manin et elle cherchait
quelqu'un pour pour charger la demander
à quelqu'un de charger la Malley dedans
les gens non ne savaient pas ce qu'il y
avait dedans et un moment elle a dit
dans la conversation je travaille pour
un don d'organe enfin elle fait une
allusion au don d'organe bon les robes
de la tuer
manifestement
c'est pas un appartenu l'après
méditation c'est la seule chose qu'on
retienne pas
parce que ça se passe le meurtre donc
c'est pas c'est évidemment sans
préméditation la qualification
criminelle qu'on retenue il y a trois
jugements dans cette affaire
les trois jugements sont tombés d'accord
pour ne pas retenir l'après-midi
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il y a eu
un enchaînement d'événements qui ont
amené à la mort le fait qu'elle soit
bâillonnée c'est pour l'empêcher de
parler forcément pour la tuer et
peut-être qu'elle est morte entre
guillemets accidentellement mais je
voudrais surtout mal suite à la malle
elle la trouve chez sa sœur elle a en
fait un cadavre d'un enfant de 12 ans au
domicile de sa sœur sa sœur était pas
présente sa sœur était au travail
elle allait rentrer du travail et donc
elle a cherché une solution
pour pour débarrasser le corps de
l'appartement
les parents ont été gardiens de cet
immeuble
il la connaissait
alors les parents connaissent la soeur
d'accord et
curieusement on parle d'une altercation
je crois que c'est eu lieu sauf que la
mère ne s'en souvient pas ne se souvient
pas d'avoir une altercation avec cette
femme et le père le Marvel plutôt
dit ouais samedi vaguement quelque chose
mais c'est la suspecte qui a dit qu'elle
avait une altercation avec eux à cause
d'un digicode c'est ça voilà c'est elle
qui dit ça c'est l'auteur qui dit en
garde à vue qu'elle a eu une
intercarcation avec les gardiens à
propos d'un c'est pas le win enfin
digicode c'est le
micro
comme elle habite à chez sa sœur et
qu'elle n'avait pas le bip pour accéder
c'était compliqué pour elle de d'aller
venir d'aller faire une course de
revenir il fallait qu'elle attende que
quelqu'un lui ouvre la porte et donc
elle avait réclamé un bip au gardien qui
a juste titre ne lui avait pas accordé
bien sûr elle a rien à faire là et il
n'y a pas de de raison qu'elle est
qu'elle est un bip